the washington journal continues it is
now just about eight o'clock east coast
time and in our next hour a conversation
with
glenn greenwald of salon.com and also
later in the program david brooks who
has a piece this morning in the new york
times called greed and stupidity
we'll be digging into some of the
details with that but glenn greenwald
thanks very much for joining us my
pleasure to be here
let me begin by something both you and
david brooks write about
in the words of another columnist simon
johnson he has a piece
in atlantic monthly called the quiet
coup what is the essence of what he's
writing about
well i think it's actually quite
frightening and if i had one article
that i could recommend
this month that every american would
read it would be simon johnson's because
he was previously the chief economist
with the international monetary fund and
has dealt with
very severe financial crises in all
sorts of countries similar to the one
with which the united states and the
rest of the world is is currently
dealing and what he says is that
the way in which the crisis has unfolded
in the united states
and i think more importantly the way in
which we're attempting to address that
crisis
is very similar to the way in which
other
emerging market nations who have
experienced grave financial collapse
and he lists argentina and russia as the
prime examples
attempted to deal with their financial
crisis and in particular what he says is
that what those
societies were characterized by more
than anything else
was domination by a very narrow
financial
elite essentially the oligarchical class
uh within the country which was able to
influence and control the government to
enact policies that were designed to
benefit
only that narrow class and because they
were so unrestrained in what they were
able to do because their control over
their government
was so virtually unlimited they were
able to run amok and
create essentially financial catastrophe
and then once that catastrophe was
created what the government would then
seek to do because it was so influenced
by the wealthiest individuals
is as a response to the crisis try and
enact even further policies
that was designed to prop up and benefit
the very oligarchs
who caused the crisis in the first place
and and what simon johnson says is that
what's happening in the united states is
exactly that that
our congress and our government are so
controlled essentially so owned
by the financial elites who caused the
crisis that what we're doing is
continuing to prop
them up at the expense of ordinary
americans one point we should mention is
that simon johnson is going to be with
us on
monday for a full hour to take your
phone calls from eight to nine eastern
time
but in his piece he says that
essentially
the finance finance industry has
effectively captured our government
well i mean i don't think there's any
doubt about that uh one of the
a colleague of his who was previously an
economist at the imf as well the same
day that
simon johnson's article came out had an
op-ed in the washington post in which he
essentially said
that goldman sachs the new york
investment bank seems to have a virtual
lock
on treasury department positions under
the clinton administration the treasury
secretary was the former goldman ceo
robert rubin
of course under president bush the ceo
who designed the bailout packages was
former goldman sachs ceo hank paulson
the current treasury secretary tim
geithner is a protege
of robert rubin his chief of staff is a
former lobbyist with goldman sachs and
that's just one firm but you look across
the government and what you see is the
financial industry through its enormous
financial resources
pouring money into the campaign coffers
of the members of congress
controlling members of the executive
branch and so each and every policy
that the executive branch under both
bush and obama
have promulgated and advocated as a
response to the crisis
has as the prime beneficiaries the
financial elites who fund them and and
who control them and
uh to whom they are inextricably linked
and it's a form of extreme corruption
in general um and i think in in a case
where there's a real crisis it's a
particular problem the other thing i
would underscore is that
if you go back and look at how the
crisis began in the 1990s the financial
industry was advocating
rigorously that many of the limitations
that existed on what they were able to
do
that were in place since the great
depression to prevent another depression
were abolished one by one on a
bipartisan basis
because they fund both political parties
and and they were able to write the laws
and those
regulations were abolished at their
behest that's what caused the financial
crisis
and that same corrupt system is still
fueling what
is intended to be the solution from the
g20 to
legalizing drugs to gitmo you're writing
about it all and we're getting
we will get into some of the specifics
do you also twitter
actually i've started to twitter um and
i i
uh i think um just to experiment with
whether it has real value
um i haven't actually seen the value
in it yet but i'm still searching with
an open mind i think actually there is a
danger
that if our communications become too
truncated and twitter has a
140 character limit on each entry um the
amount of our discourse the level of our
discourse can degrade
even further still i mean we already
have political discourse dominated by
very short
10-minute or five-minute segments in
between commercial breaks um
assuming the public has a very small
attention span i think twitter is a step
in the wrong direction um and so i do
think it
has a potential to degrade our discourse
even further we're going to try it this
morning we'll see how many
tweets we get but if you want to log on
to twitter.comwash journal and you can
if you have a an account we'll include
some of your comments as part of our
discussion with glenn greenwald
you wrote about a question that chuck
todd nbc news white house correspondent
asked president obama at last week's
news conference on the issue of
sacrifices when it comes to the economy
what were you referring to well i found
chuck todd's question unbelievably
revealing about how our media stars
think
there was a question that arose when
george bush began commencing wars in the
wake of 9 11
which was well if we're really at war
don't we need to sacrifice as americans
in other words how is it that we can go
and send our military around the world
to invade destroy and then attempt to
rebuild iraq and
occupy afghanistan and send billions of
dollars to israel and flood the middle
east with our influence how can we do
all of that
put this enormous pressure on economic
pressure and at the same time give
ourselves
huge tax cuts how can we fund this
imperialistic foreign policy and at the
same time
pay less taxes eventually the system
will collapse and don't americans need
to sacrifice over truly at war that was
the question posed to the bush
administration
so chuck todd stood up and asked that
same question
though this time to president obama in a
completely different context
in the context of the economic crisis
which he equated to a war and he said
don't americans
why aren't you asking americans to
sacrifice
it was a bizarre question because if you
don't live
as a millionaire media star in
washington you know that across the
country
the whole point of the financial crisis
is that there's enormous sacrifices
being made by ordinary americans they're
losing their jobs they're losing their
homes they're losing their retirement
security the ability to send their
children
to college and so it was both an idiotic
question and at the same time i thought
a revealing one because it was
essentially assuming
that americans aren't suffering enough
and that the key to solving the
financial crisis
the premise better than this question
was and chuck todd's question
was that it isn't the financial elites
who need to sacrifice but it's ordinary
americans they need to give up social
security benefits medicare medicaid
and that is really what the political
class is now attempting to do it's what
simon johnson actually says
was done in russia and argentina and
these other emerging
market nations is that which is that the
financial elites caused the crisis and
the government turns to ordinary
americans to demand
sacrifice and i think that's what chuck
todd was advocating let me ask you to
respond to what david brooks writes this
morning the new york times
greed in stupidity he's going to be with
us in the next hour
he says the us economy got finance heavy
and financed mad
and finally collapsed and when it did
the elites did what all elites do
they took care of their own i think
actually that's
entirely true you know again if you look
at the way in which our government
functions
it is essentially a wholly owned
subsidiary
of our financial elites and that isn't
how it was supposed to be lobbyists come
to washington on behalf of the largest
corporations and they write the laws
and that doesn't change if there's
republicans controlling the congress or
the democrats controlling the congress
the two political parties are funded
largely by the same corporate interest
to control our system of government that
was the corporate
those are the corporate uh factions that
engorged themselves greedily at the
expense of
america's financial health and they're
the ones who continue to drive how
the response is is formulated and i
think it's an extremely serious problem
that goes beyond the financial crisis
into
the fundamental corruption of how the
united states government has been
functioning
two other points first of all on
guantanamo a week ago you said one of
the problems that this government is
going to face and i'm paraphrasing
is that when these detainees are
released
they're free to talk about their
treatment is that something that the us
government is worried about
is that something that based on what you
wrote about the british government was
able to uh
to stop i don't think there's any
question that the bush administration
was very worried about that
and the obama administration
unfortunately seems to be just as
committed to keeping concealed
what it is that we did to detainees i
mean there's a debate in this country
about whether or not what the bush
administration did constituted torture
and war crimes it clearly did
whether or not we were right to do it
well if that's true then we ought to
welcome
both sides of that debate ought to
welcome having american courts
decide whether or not what the
government did was actually illegal and
we ought to welcome a full and free
airing
of what it was that was truly done to
these detainees and yet the obama
administration has been taking steps
to prevent courts from ruling on the
legality of the bush administration's
counterterrorism policies and
and that during the bush era it was
actually classified the detainees were
prevented from being heard from and and
now that some of them are being released
they're describing the brutal torture to
which they were subjected that we've
prosecuted other countries for doing his
war criminals before
and the question will inevitably rise as
these disclosures
multiply which is how is it that the
united states can have
could have uh prosecuted and and led the
crusade against this
these very acts when done by other
countries but now that our own political
leaders have authorized them and
perpetrated them
why should they remain immune from
consequences for having committed
serious domestic crimes and and the most
serious war crimes
and with all of these issues playing out
you also your most recent blog at
salon.com and there's a link by the way
through cspan.org on the issue of
legalizing drugs
some drugs and you quote joe klein who
out in time magazine this week why
legalizing marijuana makes sense and he
paraphrases it in terms of the baby
boomer generation one of their last
great crusades
of those in their 50s and 60s
is this is this something that is an
agenda item president obama
was asked about it at a town hall
meeting and almost dismissed the
question
well i think it's clearly becoming a
much more pressing question
and there's a willingness to debate
openly our drug policy far more than was
true in the past
and the reason is is that the american
criminal justice system is collapsing on
its own weight
senator jim webb from virginia recently
introduced this week actually
a bill to study criminal justice and
prison reform and he pointed to a
statistic that i think all americans
should know
which is that the united states has
become the most aggressive
nation of jailers in the entire world we
have less than five percent of the
world's population
and yet 25 percent of prisoners
worldwide are located in the united
states
huge numbers of them are there for
non-violent
drug offenders we impose the harshest
criminal justice
penalties of any country in the world we
imprison people for crimes that
everywhere in the
in the western world in the civilized
world our people are not put into
prison for um and actually been
presenting a paper later today at the
cato institute
um because in 2001 portugal
a member of the european union had a
similar problem that the united states
had an out-of-control drug problem the
more they criminalized the worse the
problem became
the more they put people in prison for
drugs the worse the problem became
and they convened a panel of experts to
study the evidence and what they
concluded was
the best possible policy approach to
enable drug
addiction to be addressed by the
government meaningfully
was to decriminalize all drugs not to
legalize them but to decriminalize them
so that
if someone takes drugs they're not
turned by the state
into criminals and what that enabled was
citizens to seek
treatment from the government without
fear of being put into prison
for being a drug addict and it freed up
enormous resources i mean we
waste billions and billions of dollars
on prosecuting and imprisoning and
arresting people for non-violent drug
possession
and that money would be so much better
put to for example
funding treatment programs and in
portugal ever since decriminalization in
2001
their drug problem has been vastly
improved and their policy their
consequence the consequences of that
policy are
far superior to virtually every other
western nation especially the ones with
harsh criminalization schemes such as
united states and great britain
we're talking with glenn greenwald he's
with salon.com and his regular column
unclaimed territory graduate of george
washington university
and nyu law school how did you go from
being a lawyer to a blogger
well it's interesting i i was actually
reading blogs throughout 2003 and 2004
and and found that the level of
political discussion there was higher
uh certainly than what was taking place
um within our established media venues
and
and essentially i began the blog not in
any
uh with any plan to become a journalist
or a writer but simply to participate as
a citizen
in that conversation about what i
thought and still
think is is the radicalism that had been
consuming the country
and the advent of the internet is such
that
citizens can simply start writing and
find a large audience
fairly quickly without having to rely
upon or or
go through the large corporations that
own our media outlets and it's really
diversified the
types and and views that are now
routinely heard
we are tracking the tweets on twitter
say that five times real fast
uh if you have any comments you can uh
twitter us and
we'll get to your emails as well but
we'll go back to the conventional format
as well with phone calls in durham new
york
with glenn greenwald good morning good
morning and thank you for the
opportunity mr greenwald um
i'm very concerned about the corporate
capture of the media
and i'm i'm sure we're on the same page
on that but i'd like to
talk about that if possible also it's
interested in the fact that
the next guest will be mr brooks who all
of a sudden has seen the light
i suspect that five years ago
he was actually seeing this flight but
it wasn't
in his interest to bring the subject up
and i'll leave it at that
well i think the caller raises a very
important point about
who it is that owns our major media
outlets i mean if you look at where most
americans get their news
increasingly it's through diversified
sources online and in blogs and
alternative media
but still overwhelmingly they get them
from a handful of
large media outlets and those large
media outlets are almost entirely owned
by
huge corporations that have very
specific self-interest
in terms of their relationship to the
government in terms of the policies that
benefit
the financial classes we were discussing
earlier and so it only stands to reason
that if you have a very homogenized set
of corporate
corporations that control and own media
outlets that the range of viewpoints
that americans will hear from those
media outlets
is extremely narrow and you can look
issue after issue from single-payer
health care to our
blind support for israel to the idea
that our political leaders shouldn't be
investigated and prosecuted when they
break the law
and what you find is that views that are
shared by enormous numbers of americans
often majorities
are simply excluded by and large from
our media discussions in these
establishment outlets and the reason is
is that these are corporate environments
um with corporate owners and and they
have very uh specific self-interest and
and there is not free discussion uh that
takes place
within those venues as far as david
brooks is concerned i think he's
symbolic though i think
that's true of lots of people is while
these policies are being implemented and
before it's evident that they
are so destructive we have lots of
political pundits and and
political commentators who support them
who cheer them on that was of course
true with the iraq war
most of the extremism of the bush
administration um and it's only once it
becomes so apparent that these policies
are so corrosive and destructive
they suddenly stand up and essentially
pretend that they were opponents of it
all along and there's very little
accountability in the journalism class
because of that
waldorf maryland good morning good
morning
um thank you c-span for having on such
an intelligent guest it's about time
you got somebody there to tell the truth
and talk straight
my question is number one where can i
get
more information to gain a better
understanding of who
and how these corporations have gained
such control
and my second question is what do you
think it's going to take
for america to wake up i mean in my mind
in my mind
we're on the brink of another civil war
in my mind and i don't see how that's
unavoidable if things stay the way that
they
are i don't understand why it's taking
people so long
to wake up and realize what's going on
and one last thing if you could i've
been hearing
a lot about this bilderberg
meeting or whatever it is can you
elaborate on who these people are and
what they do and where they're from
sure i mean essentially those questions
are all excellent and actually are quite
interrelated i mean one of the ways in
which our government functions now
is that there's very little transparency
i mean the bush administration was
obsessed
with secrecy to the point of classifying
even the most mundane details
but even before that our federal
government has been constructing rather
steadily a wall of secrecy behind which
uh they can function without any
transparency without the citizenry
knowing what they're doing
and most of what takes place in terms of
how our laws are written who's
influencing those laws
takes place behind closed doors i mean
the federal reserve has added trillions
of dollars to its
balance sheet and yet refuses to
disclose
to whom they've even lent the money
we've transferred hundreds of billions
of dollars
to corporations as part of our tarp
bailout fund
and they simply refuse to account for
how that money
was spent and so when you ask well how
is it that we can learn about
um who it is who's exerting this
influence i mean part of the problem is
is that the government which is supposed
to be transparent and open
at its very core has become almost
entirely opaque and
i think in terms of what citizens can do
there's clearly
increasing levels of dissatisfaction and
even anger
among the citizenry not breaking down
between conservatives and liberals
democrats
and republicans but simply citizens and
people who are connected to and inside
of
the government and and you hear more and
more members of the political class and
the media elites urging that this
populist anger be tapped down and turned
off and diffused
um because i think they're becoming
increasingly afraid that their corrupt
ways
um has some limit and that limit is what
the citizenry
will tolerate and unfortunately it seems
that the political class doesn't listen
to
the concerns of this of citizens unless
they're afraid of the citizenry and and
that's why i think that the level of
citizenry anger
um is actually quite overdue and
something that ought to be encouraged
and and i hope continues to increase
because it's the thing that
i think is uniquely effective in
checking the kind of corruption that
we've been discussing
we've been spending a lot of time
talking about the substance of the g20
summit in london president obama is now
in france he just wrapped up a news
conference with french president sarkozy
and these are live pictures also from
strasbourg france where president obama
is going to begin a town hall meeting a
familiar staple during the presidential
campaign and as you look at
this scene in france glenn greenwald
impression
well i think that the promise of the
obama presidency
is that it was something that could
and still might revitalize the symbol of
america as something positive
our face over the last eight years um
and before that but certainly the last
eight years intensified it
were things like people in orange
jumpsuits chained and
kneeling on the ground being disappeared
into cia black sites being tortured and
kidnapped and disappeared invading other
countries
and there's a perception as well that
it's our greed and our lack of
effective government that catalyzed the
financial crisis so there's clearly a
desire on the part of much of western
europe certainly and i think latin
america as well
for america to once again start to
become a force at least for better if
not for good
um and obama's charisma and the historic
nature of his presidency and his
eloquence
clearly has the capability to change the
way that the united states is perceived
and to
spawn actual leadership in the world
whether that actually happens whether
there will be meaningful change i think
still remains to be seen
santa barbara california is next good
morning on the democrats line
maureen mr greenwald i spoke with you
briefly about two years ago at the
blogger convention in
chicago and i spoke to you about a
particular issue and
there's been some recent developments
and so i just wanted to
update you on that because uh it
actually
uh connects directly to congress and
congress's policy failures in regards to
drugs
media um banking
uh just you know special interests that
control congress um and that is the
convention clause of article five of the
constitution
um the national group friends of the
article 5 convention
have put together a database for the
first time in american history that
showed there are over 700 applications
on the
senate and house congressional records
requesting an uh convention and um
recently there was a report out of
missouri
about the militia movement in america
and that report says and also
ohio the state legislative state
legislature in ohio is under the
impression also that we are
32 state applications towards
a national convention and so i guess
you know i just want to ask you you know
if you can
sometime in the near future um maybe
discuss you know us holding a national
convention and
simply on the grounds of the rule of law
which is that once those applications go
on record congress has to issue the call
you know it's interesting i i practice
constitutional law for
many years before becoming a political
writer and so i
have always been in the past rather
resistant to the idea that the
constitution
needs some sort of uh radical
re-examination
um i think the founders with some
exceptions got the constitution
basically right and the safeguards in it
are extremely important
and the problem is not that we don't
have the right constitution in place the
problem is that our constitution is
routinely trampled upon and violated and
we don't do anything about that having
said that
i do think that there are some radical
and fundamental problems within our
political system that very well might uh
warrant
a reconsideration of at least some of
the structures within the constitution
to determine whether or not the
constitution which at its core was
designed to place limits on the power of
the political class
needs to be supplemented and and
strengthened
uh in order to limit what what is the
out of control
uh corruption that that permeates our
our elites
the twitters are coming in twitter at
wash journal so if you want to do so
uh we welcome your participation one
comment mr greenwald
what is the solution to his position
that simon johnson is correct
and that financial elites have control
of government well i think that
i mean james madison talked about the
fact that what is necessary
is that the government fears the
citizenry and not the other way around
that the citizenry fears the government
and as i said the reason why there's
pillaging taking place on the part of
financial elites is because they think
that there are no consequences
for them to do that and thus far that's
been true i think americans are now
starting to wake up and realizing that
everything that they hold
as important aim with their financial
security
their ability to own a home their
ability to send their children to
college to have just a
a mildly respectable
standard of life is being now threatened
by this cooperative corruption on the
part of wall street and
washington and there's anger and the
anger is growing and it will continue to
grow
until that corruption is checked there i
wish i could say that the safeguards
that the founders put into place
to serve as checks on what our political
leads could do
would be working but we've seen in the
past eight years that congress and
the media are are uniquely
inept at this point or even unwilling to
impose those checks
they participate in much of what takes
place and so i think the ultimate check
will be the citizen standing up and
refusing to tolerate it any longer
another tweet he came up with that term
but anyhow glenn
talent is limited and the best are being
pulled from the same colleges
what would you have us do um i'm not
sure i understand
entirely the i think part of the essence
is it's a small group of school schools
whether it's harvard princeton yale that
we're pulling from these schools
well you know i think that uh you look
at the president's cabinet
right league yeah that's true although
the last administration
um although the president was a graduate
of yale
um sort of specialized in um
positions uh high up in the justice
department and elsewhere with graduates
of liberty college and
pat robertson's regent uh schools in
order to ensure ideological adherence to
the president's
agenda and and there are members of the
establishment who don't grow up as being
that but i think that the culture of
washington
and of wall street is so consuming and
so intense that no matter where you come
from once you arrive
there is a corrupting influence that is
very potent and unless you're
willfully resisting it i think it ends
up transforming even well-intentioned
people
who end up being essentially annexed
by by that culture and so i don't think
the problem is so much where do the
people come from
who fill these positions i think the
problem is what is it that they do once
they
fill them our next call from houston
good morning with glenn greenwald
and tell the dog to go outside go ahead
caller
you with hello good morning good morning
thank you for speaking out about
corruption
i think we have a legalized bribe system
in america with the lobbyists
and we should not allow any group money
to be contributed to campaigns
individual
contributions only from tax
i'm sorry from registered voters with
a total transparency
this group money is it's destroying our
nation
caller one of the uh tweets that we got
and this is directed to mr greenwald
saying that we should begin boycotting
major campaign contributors he says to
the republican party and demand
legislation of them
we had a case go before the supreme
court where corporations
were not allowed to give campaign
contributions
they came up with the lobby system which
is basically the same thing
i think what we need is the supreme
court of the united states
to disallow any groups to organize
pull their money together and
give their money as campaign
contributions
they can organize and give their ideas
they can have free speech
but this money thing is a legalized
bribe system they're just
buying votes and then we sit home and
wonder
why everything's in such a mess
she's exactly right it is legalized
bribery that is the fuel that drives the
city in which we're sitting which is
washington
i'll just give you one quick example
last year
numerous americans brought suit against
the their telecommunications companies
uh 18t verizon and the like um because
those companies broke the law by turning
over to the bush administration
access to the telephone calls of their
customers
without having to first obtain warrants
as the law required they broke the law
in numerous ways and they were sued by
their
customers for breaking the law and
violating their rights
and those telecommunications companies
hired the most expensive lobbyists in
washington former
bush and clinton administration
officials who called their friends in
congress
and got paid huge amounts of money to do
it and continuously pressured and
controlled
members of congress of both parties to
write a law that had no purpose
other than to immunize those
telecommunications companies
from the lawsuits that had been brought
against them i mean if ordinary
americans are sued for breaking the law
or for violating rights no
member of congress writes a law
immunizing them but because these
telecommunications companies have
scores and armies of lobbyists and pour
huge amounts of money into the campaign
coffers they
poured enormous amounts of money into
the campaign coffer for example of jay
rockefeller who was a member of the
senate intelligence committee
and he then became the leading proponent
a democrat
of writing a bill to immunize the same
people who were
pouring money into his campaign and the
congress got together
and passed a law to immunize the telecom
companies that
flood washington with money i mean it's
pure corruption it's the most
transparent form um and yet the caller
is right it's legalized the problem is
that the first amendment does guarantee
the right of petitioning the government
and freedom of speech
and spending money to petition your
government representatives is is a right
that even
corporations have so i think the
solution is
as the caller suggested for greater
transparency in this process and and
again for citizens to remove from office
whether democrat or republican members
of congress who get here
and write laws that are designed to
benefit
their corporate donors and and laws that
are actually written by
lobbyists on behalf of those donors a
couple of minor items from the morning
papers i want to get your reaction to
first from the new york times
uh bidding limbaugh farewell citing the
so-called
millionaires tax on the new state budget
rush limbaugh announcing this week
that he's packing up and leaving town he
does most of the shows from
south florida but he will no longer
broadcast from wabc in new york city
yeah you know i mean i think rush
limbaugh
uh has proven himself to be um you know
about nothing other than generating
attention
uh for rush limbaugh and the idea that
he somehow put upon or
burdened by attacks given
the extraordinarily profligate way that
he lives i think is
as much of a joke as as most of what
comes out of his mouth and i doubt
there's anyone in new york who will
lament his departure
in fact governor david patterson said if
i knew that that would be the result
i would have thought about the taxes
earlier there there you go i think
there's there are very few states um
that would do anything other than
celebrate rush limbaugh's departure
ward churchill who was acquitted a jury
finding on thursday that the university
of colorado wrongfully dismissed the
professor
who drew national attention for an essay
in which he called some of the victims
of september 11th
little eichmann's i think actually
that's a very important case
because what happened there was that uh
word churchill
expressed an opinion um which was
extremely controversial especially at
the time
um and and the essence of what he was
saying is something that typically was
not allowed to be heard
particularly back then what he was
arguing was that 911 was a
tragedy of course there are people who
died in 9 11 who were innocent and who
didn't deserve to die
um but the idea that americans were
walking around bewildered about why 9 11
happened
was something that he had a hard time
understanding and his point was is that
the united states
more than any country in the world bombs
occupies
invades interferes in other countries
specifically muslim countries
and if you're a country that
continuously has a government that bombs
and occupies and invades countries in
the middle east at some point
people in the middle east are going to
revolt against that military aggression
and launch an attack now you can agree
or disagree obviously with that view
but the idea that the government should
remove somebody
from their job especially a 10-year
professor because they've expressed
a unpopular viewpoint or even a wrong
viewpoint
is something that ought to disturb
everybody the first amendment is
designed to prohibit exactly that and
that's what the jury found and i think
all americans disagree or agree with or
churchill should celebrate that
if you're the university of uh colorado
do you bring him back on the payroll do
you
uh return him to the classroom because
right i think they're gonna
i think they're gonna be ordered to um
ultimately um that's what most likely
outcome
of this case will be assuming that the
jury verdict is sustained
and appealed if they wrongfully removed
him the remedy is to
compel his reinstatement bronson
michigan for glenn greenwald good
morning
now this is i'm glad i'm talking to you
i've tried before
i do agree on the corporations giving
too much money to our congressmen and
senators
and i i i don't blame the corporations
for trying who i blame for taking it is
the congressman and senators
but the congressmen and senators aren't
any different than
all the other people we have out in this
country that are standing around waiting
for a handout
they don't want to work they want the
government to give them some money
and we have gone round the clock with
this kind of mentality in this country
we have people that think that everybody
owes them something
they don't want to have to really stress
themselves to get it themselves
and our congressmen and senators are
getting to be the same way
they want handouts from the corporation
it's gotten to the point where everybody
wants a handout
well i find that mentality a bit bizarre
given that the
essence of the financial crisis the
reason that it's caused so much pain
is because every single month 500 000
americans who
were working and want to work have lost
their jobs because factories have closed
or companies have
laid them off so the essence of the
financial crisis is not people
sitting around refusing to work even
though there are jobs that are unfilled
the essence of the financial crisis
is that huge numbers of americans
millions upon millions
um that who were working and working
hard
uh don't have jobs anymore and have been
laid off or fired
um and so i think the problem is the
exact opposite is the one the caller
just described they're not looking for
free money they're actually looking for
work grand rapids michigan good morning
hi it seems to me like you really are
trying to stress corruption
and i would just ask you to point out
what happened with the bush
administration when they went after
spitzer because
he was going um forward
on predatory lenders the bankers
and the attorneys general in the
states i believe all 50 of them we had
initiated actions
and the federal bush had the federal
government step
in and stop it now this would
effectively have uh
have protected consumers had the
corruption
that was identified been prosecuted
and had others enforced
from the justice department but when you
have no enforcement from the top down
when you have corruption on top and you
don't prosecute and you don't impeach
bush and you don't impeach cheney and
all those corrupt characters underneath
him
then we suffer have we learned anything
yet
and i'm just hoping that president obama
does something
because we know everybody knows and if
we just
allow his his uh wonderful
manner to sort of hypnotize us to go
forward without
taking steps to create a better society
underneath
and actually punishing people so that
they can see that is the
result then we're going nowhere
and i think the allied spitzer case is a
very interesting and revealing case of
how warped our priorities are i mean he
really was
targeting and identifying and warning us
about the pervasive corruption on wall
street and
and including the very derivative
products that ended up
causing so much damage and the people
who have essentially robbed the american
people their financial security
and our government officials who
committed war crimes and tortured people
and allied are the way are us into a war
a devastating war
are people who are completely protected
and face no consequences and
essentially are immunized from the
actions of their from the consequences
of their
actions and yet elliot spitzer for what
essentially was a petty sex scandal um
having consensual sex with other adults
um was forced out of office in an
extremely unusual way he was pursuing
criminals on wall street the most
powerful criminals on wall street and
suddenly the federal government launched
a
major investigation involving wiretaps
and all sorts of
surveillance very expensive surveillance
that's virtually never done
for minor crimes like prostitution which
are generally left to investigations by
the state
and he was forced out of office and and
that crusade against wall street
corruption terminated he was the enemy
of the very wall street barons who
caused the financial crisis
and yet it's incredible that for minor
sex crimes we drive politicians from
office
for major war crimes we don't who do you
think was behind that well
the bush justice department is clearly
the
entity there's no question about that
the agency that commenced the
investigation and oversaw
the massive amount of resources that
were spent in order to engage in
surveillance on governor spitzer for
committing what we always treat as a
very minor crime which is consensual
prostitution and i think the caller
raises an important point is what
happens to the rule of law in this
country
when we allow our political leaders to
commit major crimes
and then we immunize them and commit
allow financial elites to commit major
pillaging and theft and fraud
and refrain from prosecuting them and
yet punish the politicians who are
trying to do something about it for
very minor offenses i think there's a
lot there in this spitzer case that
ought to be looked into still as to why
the justice department took those
unusual steps to
persecute him last issue kitsila this
morning the new york times writing that
some in alaska want another election as
a result of overturning or likely to be
overturning the conviction of senator
ted stevens uh who served from 1968
until last
this past january yeah that's ludicrous
we have elections
and frequently what happens is the
citizenry believes certain things the
time of the election
and it turns out later on that it isn't
true i mean in 2002
the country handed control of the united
states senate and congress to the
republican party
based on their fear-mongering that saw
on hussein was a grave threat to the
united states and possessed
weapons of mass destruction it turned
out that those were lies that he was not
a grave threat and didn't possess
weapons of mass destruction
ought we have nullified the 2002 midterm
election because it was
conducted based on false pretenses i
think the justice department was right
to drop the charges against ted stevens
because there was prosecutorial
misconduct there but it doesn't mean
that he was not guilty it just means the
prosecutors engaged in misconduct which
compelled the dismissal of those charges
time magazine saying that the g20
succeeded president obama now in france
what is your headline that came out of
the meetings yesterday
i think there's actually a big question
mark still over
whether or not the g20 nations will be
able to
reach the kind of consensus that this
crisis calls for they had some
cooperation on some broad principles
whether or not that's actually will
manifest into specific cooperative
action i think very much remains in
doubt it will we'll see if
it's anything more than some diplomatic
niceties we're getting more twitter so
you'll have to come back i will come
back for twitter anytime
glenn greenwald thank you very much from
salon.com appreciate your time
my pleasure thank you as we've been
speaking to you president obama in a
town hall meeting we're listening